MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
everybody to one more Authors
at Google talk.
I am glad to see everybody
here with lunch in their hands
because the topic
will be on food.
So today with us
is Dan Jurafsky.
He is the recipient of
a MacArthur Genius Award
and professor of Linguistics
at Stanford University.
He lives with his
wife in San Francisco.
Please welcome Dan to Google.
DAN JURAFSKY: Thanks.
Thanks so much.
Great.
Well, thanks so
much for having me.
So I want to talk
about food and I
want to start by talking
about food in America.
So we are an immigrant
nation and you
can tell that we're
an immigrant nation
by looking at the
words on our foods.
So the name of our foods like
hamburgers or frankfurter
or french fries
make it very clear,
our immigrant status and I want
to talk about ketchup, as well.
So those of you
who've been to Europe
know that there's
Hamburg and that's
where hamburgers come from and
there is Frankfurt and that's
kind of the French region.
French fries are Belgian
but close enough--
but what about ketchup?
So I want everyone to read
the words below the word Heinz
on this bottle.
Out loud, please.
AUDIENCE: Tomato ketchup.
DAN JURAFSKY: OK.
Why does it say tomato ketchup?
Right?
Ketchup is made of
tomatoes so the fact
that it says tomato
ketchup tells us something.
There's a linguistic
piece of information there
which is that it didn't
used to be made of tomatoes,
that the fact that ketchup
is made of tomatoes
is a modern
innovation and I want
to talk about this
innovation and to do
so I have to go back a
couple of thousand years
and imagine that
you're a fisherman.
You're living in Southeast
Asia, what's now southern China,
and you're speaking
a language-- one
of these ancestral languages,
Mon-Khmer, or Tai-Kadai,
the ancestors of modern
Hmong or modern Vietnamese
or modern Thai-- and
you're a fisherman
but what happens
in the dry season?
All the ponds dry
up and what you do
is you preserve your fish
in the following way.
You take rice and you
layer it over the fish
in layers-- rice and salt--
and then you put it in a basket
and you cover the
basket in a big stone
and you go away for, I
don't know, three months.
And when you come back, the
rice has gotten all goopy
from lactic acid
fermentation and the acid
has pickled the fish and
the fish is now preserved
and it keeps through
the dry season.
And you scrape off the icky,
goopy rice and you eat the fish
and it tastes kind
of like a modern ham.
And we know all this,
in fact, because back
in the fifth century, Chinese
ethnographers described
these strange Southerners and
all of their preserved fishes
and, in fact,
they're still made up
in the hill tribes of
Guangxi, in the west of China.
This exact dish is still made.
OK, so then, let's
say, 200 BCE China
which is, up till now,
been more in the north
expands into Lingnan, the area
that's now Canton and Fujian
provinces.
And these locals and all
their fermented seafoods
get assimilated and some
of them get pushed south,
some get assimilated, and
the foods get assimilated.
And all these
fermented fish dishes
spread throughout the Chinese
empire and the Chinese sphere
of influence where, for
example, they go to Japan.
And this dish of
fish and rice that's
let to sit until
everything goes sour
becomes the ancestor of
the modern dish sushi.
So it's called narezushi,
the ancestor of sushi.
And then slowly,
the dish changes.
So instead of letting the
fish get all lactic acid
and goopy-- the rice, I
mean-- you use fresh rice
and you use vinegar
to make the sourness.
And instead of, as
a refrigeration, ice
and refrigeration
come in, now instead
of letting the fish be pickled,
you can eat the fish fresh
because you can preserve
it and our modern dish,
which is a completely different
food-- a very fresh fish
and very fresh
rice-- is invented.
So we see here's one
descendent of this ancient dish
and there's lots of
other descendants
of this ancient
fish-preserving dish.
Ethnic Chinese are
sailing around,
trading with Southeast
Asia and the stars
are ethnic Chinese
settlements in Southeast Asia.
And lots of foods come and
go between the ethnic Chinese
and the people of Southeast Asia
and one of them is fish sauce.
Here's a picture of a
Fujianese fish sauce.
That's the fish sauce
that we know now
from Vietnamese
and Thai cooking.
It's a preserved fish.
Lots of other sauces
by the way, so here
is a sauce made from-- when
you make Chinese rice wine,
you use a kind of red yeast that
converts the starch in the rice
into sugar.
We can talk about the
chemistry if you want
but when you finish
making the wine,
the leftover leaves at
the bottom of the barrel
can be used to make a
very delicious chicken
dish, red rice lees chicken.
And over time, with this
trading with Southeast Asia,
you end up with what I
call a fish/soy isogloss,
meaning that south of
this line everybody
ferments fish products.
And you can see that Southern
China, this Canton and this
is Hainan Island are part
of this Southern isogloss,
whereas north of this line
people tend to ferment tofu.
Soy products, sorry.
And we end up with various
fermented soy products.
So south of this line you get
things like this fish sauce
that probably was originally
developed along the Mekong
River.
This is me in a
fish sauce factory.
These big barrels look like
wine fermentation barrels
but that's how fish
sauce is fermented.
This is a picture
from my honeymoon.
It was very, very romantic.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so then, now
it's about 1600.
Chinese have spread out
and now the Europeans
enter the picture.
Europeans are looking for
spices, textiles, porcelain.
This is the age of exploration.
If you will, the Silicon
Valley of Europe at the time--
the money to be
made was all in Asia
and so Europeans were all
heading to Asia to make money.
And imagine that
you're a sailor, now,
on one of these ships
and you're spending
nine months on a boat
on the way to Asia
going through the tropics.
It's very hot.
It's hard to get
fresh water so you
bring beer and
wine along and hops
have not yet been invented.
Here's a picture of hops.
Hops is a thing you add
to beer that preserves it
and they haven't
figured this out yet.
The Dutch have figured out
but the English haven't quite
got it yet.
The English are
very conservative
about these things.
And so the beer and wine,
they go bad in the heat.
And they get to
Indonesia and they're
very excited because they
find ethnic Chinese making
this thing called
Arrack, and Arrack
is the first commercially
produced distilled liquor.
So distillation
was invented twice
in the history of the world.
Once by the Arabs,
once by the Chinese
and there was a kind of
fight about whether it
was really just once
and got borrowed,
but let's assume twice.
And so these ethnic Chinese
fish sauce and soy sauce makers
are also distilling
alcohol from palm wine
and that same red
rice that they were
making into this lovely
delicious dish-- they were
distilling that into Arrack.
The word comes from the
Arabic word for sweat
because, as you probably
remember from high school
chemistry, you distill
things by boiling things
and then you put
a pot over the top
and you let the drops of
the distillate drip off
and that's your alcohol.
So they're very excited.
The Chinese are
making this Arrack,
and the thing about
hard liquor like Arrack
is it doesn't go
bad in the heat.
So they're very excited.
They buy it and if you add
it to water, kills germs.
It's like the perfect medicine.
They're very excited.
And they buy thousands
of barrels of Arrack--
the British Navy-- and it
becomes the common drink
of Europeans throughout Asia.
And, in fact, sailors
add limes, which
they're caring for scurvy,
to this newly bought Arrack
and that ends up inventing the
world's first cocktail called
Punch.
So cocktails are invented
at the same time.
So they're buying this liquor
and while they're there
they pick up some
barrels of the local fish
sauce because why not?
And you're in a boat,
you have lots of room,
you could sell it maybe.
And it turns out that this fish
sauce in one of the Fujianese
dialects-- Southern Min
is the technical name
for the family of
Fujianese languages
and the dialect in the Zhangzhou
region, the word for fish sauce
is ketchup from an old word
for salted fish that's died out
and now the word can mean
salmon in different dialects
and other kinds of fish.
And chiap still means sauce
in various Southern dialects.
So the British buy this fish
sauce, this ketchup-- which
is what it was called, ketchup--
and they bring it home.
And we know all this because,
in 1703, the British East India
Company traders, these young men
trying to make their fortune--
one of them who wrote
the details of his travel
to what he called India
which is what we would now
call all of Asia.
He was mostly in what we
now call Southeast Asia
but he also went to Hong
Kong and he and he also
went to India.
And he talks about how
important this commodity is,
this ketchup, and here's
how he talks about it.
I'll read it for you just
because the font is very faint.
"Soy comes in Tubs from Japan
and the best ketchup from
Tanqueen"-- Tanqueen is like
Northern part of Vietnam--
"yet good of both sorts are made
and sold very cheap in China.
So he talks about how he buys
fish sauce and soy sauce-- fish
sauce which he calls
ketchup-- in Hong Kong
and soy sauce in Hong Kong.
And he also says, "I know not
a more profitable Commodity."
And the reason is this stuff
is an exotic, imported sauce.
He's selling this back in
London, making a lot of money
at it.
They actually bring
bottles all the way
to Asia-- empty bottles--
they fill them with fish sauce
and they bring them back.
I don't know why they
don't do it in barrels
but that's what they did.
So he actually advises young
people who want to go to Asia
and make their money, make sure
you fill the ship with bottles
on your way out.
Empty bottles.
It's very interesting.
Anyway, so you've got
this really expensive,
imported luxury.
So what do you do if you
want to make some money?
You make knockoffs of this
expensive, imported luxury.
So there are almost immediately
recipes for fake ketchup.
So here's a recipe
for fake ketchup.
It involves beer.
It involves anchovy.
So it's still fish sauce
but there's beer in it
and it's got what had become
European spices by now.
Cloves, and pepper, and ginger
but it's also got mushrooms,
and shallots.
And you boil it and
you can tell they're
trying to copy an Asian
sauce because it says,
"This is thought to exceed
what is brought from India."
Again, India at the
time means Asia.
So they're trying to
copy this Asian sauce
and they invent something with
still fishy but other flavors
and then the recipe
changes over the years
and they start to add other
ingredients that are salty
and have glutamates in them
and one of those is walnuts.
So here is, from Jane Austen's
family recipe, actually,
for walnut ketchup.
So again, it's walnuts and
vinegar and various spices
and horseradish.
Sounds-- yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So then, about 1800, tomatoes
come from the New World.
So tomatoes are a
Mexican fruit, of course,
and they come via
Portugal and Spain.
Eventually they get to
England and eventually they
come to America.
We didn't get them directly
through from Mexico.
They had to come and
be baptized by Europe.
And the first tomato
ketchups are salty.
They're made with anchovies.
So it's tomatoes and anchovies.
It's an anchovy, salty sauce.
Notice that it will
keep for seven years.
So these are preserving methods.
And then our favorite drug
is invented-- not invented,
but it becomes cheaper-- sugar.
Sugar becomes much cheaper and
right around the Civil War,
the anchovies disappear
and, Especially in the US,
we start adding a lot
of sugar to this recipe.
The vinegar is still there,
but now instead of salt we
add sugar and you end up with
our modern tomato ketchup,
which is basically a chutney.
It's basically a sweet and sour
chutney if you think about it,
is what ketchup is.
So why am I telling you this?
So one reason is, we think of
ketchup as an All-American food
but really it's not
just an American food.
It's a world Food.
And the history of how
it became this world food
and all of its cousins-- right.
It's a first cousin once
removed-- twice removed,
maybe-- to sushi and it's
related to fish sauce.
It's to all of these things
and all of these innovations
were made by individual
chefs who took this food
and changed something
about it to make
it conform to their own
particular cuisines.
And if you think about it, a
recipe is just a technology.
Right.
These are all people
inventing new technologies
by going to some
foreign country,
stealing their technology and
trying to recreate it at home
and getting it wrong but, in
the process, creating something
exciting and interesting.
So I call this the ketchup
theory of innovation which
says, innovation happens
when you borrow and extend
the ideas of your
neighbors and often, it
happens because you physically
go somewhere and talk
to somebody.
And I won't talk
about this but we
have tons of
research in our lab--
you can ask me in the
question session-- about,
for example, how probability
theory entered my field--
natural language processing.
And it entered because a
bunch of electrical engineers,
in 1988, went to a
computer science conference
and presented a bunch of math
and all the computer science
graduate students
were very excited
and started borrowing
it and changing it
and things happened.
People actually physically
had to go somewhere on a boat
or in a plane and so that's
how innovation happens.
And there's lots
of other stories.
I won't tell you
lots of all of them
but you can ask me
the question session.
But one fun thing--
because today
is both Diwali and
Veteran's Day--
is the story of how ice cream
comes from military technology.
And I won't tell
you the whole story
but you can ask me about it.
But the short
version of the story
is that ice cream is a
descendent of gun powder.
Gun powder, which
uses saltpeter,
which is potassium nitrate, has
interesting cooling properties.
And the reason why we use
the word sherbet, which
comes from an Arabic
word for drink,
and sorbet-- sorbetto and
sorbet and these words
is because of the Muslim
history of ice cream
which you can ask
me about later.
And, in fact, the julep
in mint julep-- julep
was the old word we used to use
for any kind of sugar syrup,
and it comes from
the Persian word
for rose water, which is there
in gulan jamun, the desert
that I pictured there.
So there's all sorts of fun
links I've shown you from China
but there's lots, also, from
the Middle East and Persia.
All right.
So that's my little
history segment
and now I want to
talk about identity
and I have a lovely
photograph staged by my friend
Stephanie of why potato chips
should be considered a luxury
food.
And I'm going to talk about
how potato chip packaging
words reveal identity,
and this is research
that I started with a freshman
at Stanford, Josh Friedman, who
I've shown over
there in the corner.
And I had a freshman class
called The Language of Food
and the students got interested
in language in different ways
and Josh had the brilliant
idea of looking at potato chips
and, being a freshman, he went
to the Safeway on El Camino
and just took pictures of all
of the bags of potato chips
because he was too
cheap to buy them.
And so this is our data set and
he brought it back-- the backs.
The fronts and the backs.
And then the class, we all kind
of looked at them together.
So this is a sample
from our corpus.
This is the kind of
things that people
say in the back of
potato chip bags.
You may never have read the
back of your potato chip bags
but this is what they say.
And we were relying
on this work by
the famous French
sociologist, Pierre Bourdieu,
and what Bourdieu said was,
he looked at French tastes
in the 1960s and he
compared the working class
and the upper class--
the professional class.
And what he noticed was
the working class had taste
that we now think of as
kind of populist taste,
like they liked Strauss.
That was a thing for the
working class to like.
They liked The
Blue Danube waltz.
And they had these very heavy,
starchy meals-- cassoulet,
which has got beans
and duck confit
and it's really heavy
and solid, whereas
the professional
class-- the bour
geois-- they had
these refined tastes.
They liked Bach.
They're liked Bruegel.
And they were eating
these new ethnic foods
that were just coming
into France at that time.
Curry and brown rice was
all very novel and exciting
in the 60s.
And what he said
was, there is nothing
absolutely better or worse
about cassoulet than curry.
The fact that one of them
is eaten by the high-class
and one of them is
eaten by low-class
is completely an arbitrary
marker of status.
It could've been the
other way around.
In fact now, cassoulet is a
marker of fancy French food
here.
So he said these are just ways
of distinguishing ourselves
and that society comes
up with these ways
and he specifically
said, when we're
talking about what
counts as good taste,
that taste is about distaste.
That what it is to have the
taste of the upper class
is just to be different
than the poor people.
We don't care what
they do as long as what
we do is different than them.
That was his model
of what it is.
So he said, taste is
negation, sick-making.
He's very visceral,
he says this.
So we thought, well, maybe
this is true in potato chips.
Let's look at how
expensive potato chips look
different than
cheap potato chips
on this Bourdieu
distinction idea
and so we just counted
the linguistic markers
of distinctions.
So we looked at comparison
words like more or less,
words like least or unique, and
then we just counted the number
of negations-- the
number of no's and not's.
And sure enough, we
found five times more
of linguistic markers
of distinction
in the expensive chips.
So here's are some examples.
Deliciously different,
best in America, less fat,
won't find in any other chip.
And in particular, a lot
of negation, and, in fact,
you pay for this negation.
So every time you add
one negative word,
you're paying four
more cents per ounce
and I want to show you the back
of the most expensive potato
chip bag in our sample.
I'll let you read it.
Nothing fake or phony.
No fake colors, no
fake flavors, no--
t so there's lot of no's
and not's and nothing's.
We also found, by the way,
that potato chips turn out
to be a health food.
So all potato chips talk
about how natural they are.
They are the most
natural and healthy food
you could possibly
buy if you believe
the advertising on the back.
It's kind of exciting to know.
I'm going to stop eating
bananas and eat potato chips,
but it turns out that expensive
chips do this six times
more often than cheap chips.
So, for example, no chips
have trans fats in them
but only the
expensive bags talked
about the lack of trans fats.
So it's something about
health and the appeal
to health in the upper class.
Cheap chips, by contrast,
appeal to an idea
of traditional authenticity.
So cheap chips are
more likely to talk
about the founder,
the age of the recipe,
tradition, kind of conservative
words, classic American,
locales in America.
Expensive chips are
more likely to talk
about what we call
natural authenticity, so
the lack of
artificialness, the fact
that they're natural, the fact
that they're hand-processed.
All of these
differences in metaphor.
All right.
So just from potato
chips, you've
seen all sorts of-- from a very
small data of 14 potato chip
bags, we suggest there are
these really big differences
in how class is
represented in America.
Traditional versus
natural authenticity,
the role of negation,
the role of health.
And we decided to
follow this study up
by looking at more data because
14 is a very small data set.
So we looked at a much
larger data set of menus,
and this is with Victor
Chahuneau and Brian Routledge
and Noah Smith who are
friends from Carnegie Mellon.
And we looked at online
menus from 6,000 restaurants
and we looked, again, at
how the wording differed
by the price of the restaurant.
So for example, look at
these lovely adjectives.
Your zestys, your rich,
your crispys, your fluffys,
your golden brown.
Here's some examples.
Rich, creamy, spinach
artichoke dip.
Creamy, homemade fettuccine.
And then let's just plot the use
of those, the amount of them,
by the price of the restaurant.
And we used the Yelp criteria
of one, two, three, and four
dollar sign restaurants.
So there's our
adjectives and you'll
see big bumps in the two
and three dollar sign
restaurants, especially the
two dollar sign restaurants.
That's your California
Pizza Kitchens
and your Cheesecake Factories
and your lower-middle-priced
restaurants.
Lots of mentions of these
beautiful adjectives
whereas the cheaper
restaurants, instead
of using the crispys
and the creamys,
they use these very vague
adjectives that you can't
really disagree-- if
they say it's crispy
and it's not crispy, you
can complain to your waiter,
but if they say it's
flavorful and you say,
well, it wasn't
really flavorful,
that's really a
matter of choice.
And sure enough, lots more
of these vague adjectives
in the cheap restaurants.
So why would--
these two facts be--
why would it be that the
expensive restaurants don't
have any of these words and it's
the cheaper restaurants that,
say, mention that
their food is fresh.
And there's a lovely linguistic
literature from the philosopher
Grice who argues as follows.
Why would I tell you
that the food is fresh?
Well, the reason I
tell you something
is because you don't know
what I'm trying to inform you
about something you don't know.
I want you to know
the food is fresh.
Well, why would you not
know the food is fresh?
You might think the
food isn't fresh
and have to be convinced and,
if I'm an expensive restaurant,
that's a bad proposition.
I don't want you to be thinking
that you need to be convinced
the food is fresh.
I'm just not going to
mention it and we'll just
both assume that
the food is fresh
if it's supposed to be fresh.
And that's, in
fact, the mechanism
that high-priced restaurants
take in their menus.
And, for those of you
interested in game theory,
there's even a
cute game theoretic
proof of this which I won't
go into but-- OK, I will.
So imagine that you have three
prices-- because game theory is
very easy to explain.
The math is harder but the
explanation is very simple.
Imagine you have high, mid,
and low-priced restaurants
and then imagine there's some
other noisy cues to quality
like location or
expense, so that you
have some vague idea
whether the restaurant is
in class A, B, or C.
Expensive, mid-priced, or low.
What the proof shows is that the
high-class restaurants, no one
confuses them with
the cheap restaurants
because you have these
other cues like the decor
or something.
But the people might be
confused with the restaurant
next to them, so
cheap restaurants
might be confused
with middle class
and middle class might be
confused with expensive.
So the optimal strategy is for
the middle-priced restaurants
to signal, say, I'm great, so
that you think that they're not
the cheap restaurants and
then the expensive restaurants
counter-signal--
don't say anything--
to show that
they're not the same
as the mid-priced restaurants.
And so, the result is what
the advertising literature
technically calls
modest advertising.
Modest advertising, something
that the high-class--
that's why you get these
Tiffany's ads with lots
of white space on the
page and a little diamond
right in the middle.
We're using lots of
blank space to indicate
that we don't have to
brag about our-- it just
speaks for itself.
We're expensive.
And this same idea,
this Gricean idea, you
can see this just in vocabulary.
So, the word real, not used at
all in expensive restaurants.
On cheap restaurants--
the cheapest ones--
you get real whipped cream
and real mashed potatoes
and real bacon.
You pay a little
more money you might
get real crab and
real maple syrup,
but again, as you
go up the hierarchy,
when you're at this
kind of restaurant
you assume that the potatoes
are actually made of potato
and when you're at
these restaurants
they want you to assume
everything is real.
So you can learn a lot just
by counting these words.
You can also, actually,
learn about history
by looking at the word real.
Those of you who were
alive in the 70s and 80s
may remember that there
were various-- well,
there is still Cool Whip,
these imitation whip creams
and various imitation
sour creams.
And we looked at-- there's a
recipe collection at the New
York Public Library.
It's very fun.
You can check it out online.
You can also crowdsource
helping transcribe the menus.
I said recipes but I
meant menu collection.
And you can look
back through time
at when words like
real and genuine-- what
most likely the head
that they modify is.
And real bacon, right about the
time bacon bits were invented,
and real whip cream just
after Cool Whip was invented,
and real butter soon after
margarine became popular.
And if you go back to 1900,
they had mock turtle back then
because turtle soup
was very popular
and they made a
fake turtle soup,
but the most common thing to
talk about in 1900 on a menu
that you bragged
about was the fact
you had actual
German beer because
the great German immigration,
that was probably the largest
immigration to America, happened
in about the 1860s, 1870s.
And Americans before that drank
what we now would call ale.
They drank dark beer, not lager.
And the Germans brought what
was not the norm for beer here,
was all brought by the Germans
and and so right around 1800,
New York, for example, was full
of these German beer houses
and restaurants were beginning
to serve beer and beer
became popular and
associated with being
German because it was the
Germans that brought it.
And so you had real German beer.
So you can actually
look at the history
of American food,
immigration, and imitation
just by counting what
we modify with real.
OK, so that's all
techniques we talked about
for cheap restaurants.
What do expensive
restaurants do?
They use rare words.
Many of you will have seen this
if you go to fancy restaurants.
You have to ask the waiter
one of the words mean.
I just put some of these up.
And even if you know
what the words mean,
they'll use longer
versions of them
and not the shorter
versions of them.
So decaffeinated for
expensive restaurants,
decaf for cheap restaurants.
And that suggests-- both of
these facts-- these are all
long-looking words, suggest
we could measure word length
and sure enough the average
length of a word in a menu
is correlated with the price.
And you are, again, paying
for those extra letters.
So longer words, more expensive
menus but, by contrast,
more words, cheaper menus.
So the most expensive
menus have long words
but there aren't
very many of them.
So this is Saison, a very fancy
restaurant in San Francisco
and, at the time I went, they
had no menu but we asked them,
please could we have a menu?
And they very kindly
emailed us a PDF.
You can see that it's in a very
light font because they really
didn't want to give us a
menu, although the food was
very excellent and
they were very nice.
So I'm just picking on
them, but anyway, you
can see that the dishes are
described with single words
so, trout roe, abalone, cardoon.
It says brassica, not cabbage,
which is the more frequent word
but brassicas is the rare word.
So that's what an expensive
menu looks like in America
right now.
This is, by contrast, what
a cheap menu looks like.
Of course, that's The
Cheesecake Factory
and that's just page one.
There are 20 pages on this menu.
OK, so, more differences.
Cheap restaurants, that same
traditional authenticity
that we saw in
cheap potato chips.
The mentioning of words like
old-fashioned and homemade,
mentions of female relatives
like grandmas and aunts
and moms.
By contrast, exactly
as with potato chips,
the expensive restaurants
talk about where
the food comes from.
The fact that it
was fed on grass,
that it was raised in a pasture,
the name of the farm where it
was fed this grass and so on.
Mentions of where the food
comes from, vastly more common
in expensive restaurants.
Now, just as with ketchup,
where ketchup was this expensive
imported sauce and now it's the
cheapest food that all children
grow up on here.
Sociologists-- so Vablen,
who was actually at Stanford,
and Georg Simmel-- pointed
out that stuff trickles down
from the rich.
Some things get
borrowed from the poor,
some things get
borrowed from the rich
and these ideas seem
to have trickled down.
So in the early 20th
century, fancy restaurants
were in French and
they were very long
and they had lots
of descriptions
and that idea seems
to have trickled down
to two star restaurants
like The Cheesecake Factory
with these long menus.
And now the expensive menus,
by contrast, are really short.
Taco Bell just closed
one of these failed ideas
they had called US
Tacos, where they
were going to have
a taqueria that
looked like an
expensive restaurant
and you can see
that on the menu.
So, like expensive menus,
they didn't use "and",
they had just commas between
the names of the dishes
and they had fancy
words in it and they
had kind of cutesy
names and it basically
closed because
people were confused
about whether this was
a hipster restaurant
or whether it was Taco Bell.
AUDIENCE: They should have
just charged more money.
DAN JURAFSKY: They should
have just charged more money
and just not mentioned.
Another fun fact, I call
this the Tiki Lounge effect,
so if you see words like
exotic, oriental, spices,
or even spicy-- seems like a
very innocuous word, spicy--
on the menu, here are some
examples of what I mean.
I just got these
from various menus.
So if you think about it, why
would you call a food spicy?
So if it's your native
cuisine, it's not spicy.
It's just how the dish tastes.
Spicy is a word you used to
describe somebody else's food
to say that it has spices
I wasn't expecting,
or you might need to be
warned about, or so on.
Exotic is a much more explicit
way of saying that it's not us,
it's them.
So these are all names
that you use when you're
serving to non-native eaters.
Right.
A native chef cooking
for a native eater
wouldn't use those words
because it would make no sense
and so that suggests
that, in fact, they're
going to charge more for this
because you're selling it
to tourist eaters, if you will.
And sure enough, if you
use those words in a dish,
you're going to charge
more for that dish.
We ran a little
regression on price.
All right.
So summaries of menus.
Expensive menus are
linguistically modest.
We saw effects of
health and authenticity
and their interaction
with class.
We talked about trickle-down
effects and fun things
like cues for exoticism.
There's a lot you
can see in menus
and I want to now turn
to restaurant reviews.
So I've shown you a one star,
really bad restaurant review.
I've modified it slightly so
you can't Google the words
and see who wrote this because
I don't want to embarrass
anybody, but anyway, somebody
had a bad time at a restaurant
and wrote this one
star review and I
want you to just take a
look at it for a second.
What do you notice
about this review?
It doesn't mention
the food at all.
Right?
There is no mention of
food in this review.
So we thought, going into
this project, that one star
reviews would be
people complaining
about greasy food
or ill-cooked food
and what we found
instead when we
focused on the one star
reviews was these three or four
factors.
Negative sentiment language,
that wasn't surprising.
They use words like bad or
disgusting or horrible or
awful.
Then they had a
lot of past tense,
so rather than the present
tense they used the past tense.
We waited, we didn't, he was.
And lots of mentions of people.
So, third person pronouns, names
of roles of people-- managers,
and customers, and waiters--
and kind of surprisingly,
way more mentions
of the first person
plural-- we, us,
our, ourselves--
than we expected by chance.
So lots of reviews might
use I or they might use we.
So there's a base rate for
what you use them both in
and it was way higher in
these one star reviews
for the use of we and us.
And we looked at the
literature to see
what other genre of writing
has these exact features.
Negative sentiment, past
tense narratives about people,
overuse of we and us,
and we did find a genre
with exactly these
characteristics
and it's the genre
of people who write
after they'd been traumatized.
And so there's a literature
on this, so a lot of this
is from Texas in
the Pennebaker lab.
So they looked at people
blogging after 9/11, they
looked at students who write
after tragedies on campus,
and the idea is they're using
the past tense to distance
themselves from this bad thing
happened but it's in the past.
We're going to get through it.
And you use the
we and us and our
because this bad
thing happened but it
happened to us collectively
and, again, we'll
get through it together and
so it's a mark of trauma.
So, really, these
one star reviews
are minor trauma narratives
and the important lesson
is that you think
these reviews are
objective descriptions of
some product flaw or something
and that's why you're
looking at them, if you're
a company reading
your own reviews,
but really they're
describing these facts
about personal actions.
Somebody was mean to a person
and face-to-face rudeness
is extremely traumatizing
even though it's obviously
a minor trauma.
Nonetheless, face-to-face
interaction matters a lot.
OK, so that's the
negative reviews.
The positive reviews,
here's an example
of phrases from
a positive review
but not every positive review
talked about sex-- only
the expensive ones.
And you probably all know
that sex is not cheap
but what is cheap, it turns
out, is addiction, crack,
and craving.
So, the cheaper the restaurant,
the more likely people
were to use drugs as their
metaphor for the food.
So why drugs?
Well if you think
about it, these foods
that they're talking about
in these cheap reviews,
they're talking about chicken
wings, and french fries,
and chocolate.
A lot of desserts.
So they're feeling guilty.
So partly, drugs
is a negative thing
and I'm feeling
guilty about thinking
of these foods as
a negative thing
so that's a good
metaphor but it also,
by using the metaphor of
drugs, you're saying it's
not my fault. Some of
the agency of this eating
is not my agency.
I didn't choose to
eat that cupcake,
I was medically forced
to eat the cupcake
and it's not my fault, right?
We know that women are much
more pressured to conform
to these norms of
healthy eating and women
were much more likely to
use this metaphor of food
as a drug than men.
Men, by contrast, by
the way, were much more
likely to display trauma
in those one star reviews.
So men were more traumatized,
women are more guilty.
Do with that as you will.
All right.
I'll very briefly talk
about food requests.
So this was a study
where we wanted
to know-- there's lots of
online funding mechanisms
where people ask for things and
you give them what they want.
And we want to
know, because we're
linguists, what does the
language matter in whether they
get the thing they ask
for online and the problem
with studying that--
it's very hard to study
that because obviously it
depends on what you ask for.
If you ask for a
million dollars,
you're much less likely to get
it than if you ask for $10.
So to study any of these
crowdfunding platforms,
we need to control, extremely
strictly, for the thing they're
asking for.
And so we picked a
subreddit in which
everyone asked for the same
thing, which was a pizza.
It's called Random
Acts of Pizza.
You ask for pizza and they
either do or don't give you
a gift certificate for pizza.
And so let's look at
the language of one
of these requests for pizza.
This is a sad story.
Sorry to give you sad
stories but this is somebody
who really needed that pizza.
There's unemployment, there's
all sorts of problems.
And let's look at
the linguistics going
on in their request for pizza.
So they do things
like reciprocity.
So reciprocity, in
social psychology,
is I do something for you,
you do something back for me.
Generalized reciprocity
is I do something for you
and you do something
for somebody else
and kind of pass on the favor.
So we coded, just wrote
regular expressions and things,
to code-- we have lexicons
and things-- to code
for generalized reciprocity.
We coded for length,
maybe it matters
to ask with longer,
longer requests.
We coded evidentiality.
So this is a
picture that someone
posted of their bank account,
showing they only had $5 in it.
And so we quoted how much
they mention the evidence.
We coded status.
Reddit has karma so maybe people
who are high-status or have
been-- presumably, having
high karma on Reddit
means that you're a
good person and you've
helped out other people and
done a bunch of good stuff,
so maybe that gets
rewarded on Reddit.
We can check that.
And, just to cut to
the chase very quickly,
it turns out that
if you add up all
of these pro-social
behaviors they
are, in fact, one of the most
significant factors-- maybe
the most significant
factor-- in whether you're
going to get that pizza.
So if you promise to pay it
forward, if you say thank you,
if you have karma
in the community,
you're going to get your pizza.
So that suggests
that good behavior
is awarded, which is good.
And for my last
topic I want to go
to something that seems even
more surprising, at the time,
to us.
And this is the
idea that how you
name a food could
actually matter
in what's going on in the food.
So if you think about
names, the classic theory
of how names work or how
words work in general--
how words match objects--
is called conventionalism.
And this is a famous formulation
in "Romeo and Juliet."
"What's in a name? that which
we call a rose By any other name
would smell as sweet."
It doesn't matter that
we use the sounds rose
to describe a rose.
If we have some
other language, we'll
have some other word for it.
That's OK, too.
And it turns out that
there is an alternative
to conventionalism called
naturalism, something
that actually Plato talks about
in the Cratylus, very famously.
And here's how Plato says it.
That there is an
"inherently correct" name,
everything has its
own perfect name,
and not just in Greek
but even for barbarians,
which is to say the best of
us, that there is an inherently
correct name for everything.
And what could
this possibly mean?
It makes no sense at all.
But it turns out it's
true, in some sense,
and I want to talk
about that sense.
So, first I have
to show you mouths.
So these are
midsagittal, meaning cut
through the body this way,
views of the tongue, the upper
and lower lips, the
upper and lower teeth.
And there are two classes of
vowels cross-linguistically,
and they're called
front vowels and back.
So front vowels are ones in
which, very roughly speaking,
the tongue is more toward
the front of the mouth.
So you can see how the tongue
is kind of more up here and back
vowels, roughly
speaking, the tongue
is in the back of the mouth.
So front vowels,
that's your ee, ih, eh.
Ee, ih, eh.
Watch my mouth.
I get wider and the tongue
is up there. can't really
see the tongue but it's there.
And the back vowels,
that's your oh, aw.
Oh, aw, ooh.
The tongue is more in
the back of the mouth.
And it turns out that,
across languages, these
seem to be associated--
it's called
sound symbolism-- associated
with different concepts.
So across lots of
languages, front vowels
are used for small things.
So we have in English,
little, itsy bitsy,
teeny weeny all
have ih, ee vowel
but it's true in
lots of languages.
Your ee in petite in
French and your ito in lots
of Spanish words.
And, by contrast, back
vowels used in words
like huge-- huge, very big right
now-- and humongous, and large.
Huge.
And, again, cross-linguistically
this is generally true.
So we thought, well, this is
a generally widely-known fact
about language.
Maybe it's true
for food as well.
And we looked at
crackers versus ice cream
and our idea was, well,
crackers, those are small.
They're meant to be light,
meant to be delicate.
Maybe they're going to use more
front vowels in their names
whereas ice creams, you
want an ice cream to be big
and plump and solid
and heavy and so maybe
we'll use back vowels and I
just scraped some cracker brand
names from a website and took
all of the Haagen-Dazs and Ben
and Jerry flavor names
as my ice cream database.
So, very quick study.
And so here's the crackers.
Please repeat the names as you
see them on the screen with me.
Krispy.
Ritz.
Wheat Thins.
Triscuit Thin Crisps.
Cheeze-It.
Chicken in a Biskit.
OK.
You get the idea, right?
Lots of ih's and ee's,
whereas an ice cream--
here's some ice cream names.
Rocky Road.
Jamoca Almond Fudge.
Chocolate, Carmel,
Coconut Cookie Dough.
All ah's and oh's and ooh's.
And sure enough,
here's my lovely graph.
That blue is front vowels
and green is back vowels
and you get much more
front vowels with crackers
and much more back
vowels with ice creams.
So why would this be?
There's a standard explanation.
Front vowels have a
particular low pitched,
one of the formants
for front vowels--
sorry, front vowels have
a high pitched resonance.
Front vowel is made
by putting the tongue
in the front of the mouth.
In the amount of space in front
of that, before the teeth,
is a small cavity.
Small cavity, high frequency
waves get to fit in there.
Think of it that way.
And back vowels,
they're in the back
and there's a much bigger
cavity in the mouth.
So there's a lot of high
pitches with front vowels
and low pitches with
back vowels and we
know that high pitches
are made by squeaky,
little animals like little birds
and little mice make squeaks.
And big lions make big
roars and low pitches
and, instinctively, we
associate pitch with size
and somehow, that
works for language.
So it's not just front
vowels and back vowels,
there's actually
other cases of this.
So, let me show you
two pictures and let's
suppose there's words for
these pictures in Martian
and one of them is maluma, or
the other dialect of Martian
calls it bouba, and one of
these is takete, or kiki.
So which of these is
the takete-kiki picture?
The spiky one, right?
Everyone has that
same intuition?
There's something about that
that looks more takete or kiki
and it turns out that this
is also true for food.
So this is the work from
the Spence lab at Oxford
that people use
words like takete
to describe dark chocolate,
maluma to describe
milk chocolate.
They use maluma to
describe still water,
takete to describe carbonated
water and, I didn't mention
this before, but in
our cracker study,
lots of crackers have T's and
K's in their names whereas ice
cream is more likely
to have L's and M's.
So, in summary, M's
and L's are associated
with these creamy,
gentler tastes and T and K
with these sharper tastes.
So why would this be?
And I'll show you
a picture of me.
This is a sound wave of me
saying maluma and takete
and you can see, maluma is
is a much more continuous
sound wave.
The way you make the T's
and K's of takete is you
actually close your mouth,
let air pressure build up
behind the tongue in various
places, open your mouth,
the air explodes out.
So you see these little
bursts of explosion.
So, in fact, the sound of
takete is very sharp and jagged
and explosive in the
real world and maluma
is very smooth in
the real world.
And this suggests that something
synesthetic is going on.
Synesthesia is the
general case when people--
one sense interferes
with another sense,
or the two senses are
involved in each other.
So somehow, vision, that
you saw with those pictures,
are a sense of a picture
being a picture being curvy
versus jaggedm taste,
creamy versus sharp
and sound, sharp versus
smoothness in acoustic,
are all subconsciously linked.
And I want to suggest
that both of these facts,
the fact about front
and back vowels
and the fact about smooth
versus sharp consonants,
may have evolutionary
implications.
So there's an acute idea
from phonetician John Ohala.
So, if you think
about it, when you
make the first front
vowels, those ee,
ih eh's, you have to
pull your mouth back.
Ee, ih, eh and you
instinctively have to smile.
So that's why we have the
word cheese in English
for taking a picture
because cheese forces you--
any front vowel--
forces you to smile.
And what Ohala suggested
is maybe smiles evolved
very early in mammalian
history to make yourself sound
physically smaller
because, by smiling, you're
dropping this size
of this formant
and it's like, I'm
small, don't hurt me.
So that was his--
smiling is like, eh.
It's going to be OK.
And maybe it solves
this other problem,
which is, how could language
possibly have evolved?
How did the first
listener know what
the first speaker was saying?
Right?
Like that first word,
how did they know?
And one theory, it's called
the Bootstrap theory,
said maybe some of
the sound symbolism
could have been a
possible bootstrap.
So maybe the very
first cavewoman
talking to the very first other
caveperson used like a sound
with an ee in it to mean
baby, like ee, little ee,
and used some kind of
oo, ooh sound to mean big
or says kikikikiki to
mean something sharp
and then you have a couple
of words and then, with that,
bootstrapping goes
on from there.
All right.
So, summarizing, we
learned that innovation
happened at interstices.
This is a general
fact about innovation,
as we're borrowing
ideas of our neighbors.
We learned that
people don't like it
when you're mean to
them, so don't do that,
and they reward you if you're
kind, which is a good thing.
Society's roughly
working in the right way.
And, bottom line, you can tell
a lot about all sorts of things.
Psychology,
economics, evolution,
if you look very carefully
at the language of food.
So I'll stop there
and take questions.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Has
anybody come to you
from marketing departments
from either restaurants or food
companies to use this to
come up with better names?
It seems like they
already have it.
DAN JURAFSKY: They
totally already have it.
I have talked to a bunch
of advertising people
and so branding companies
already use sound symbolism.
So branding companies
are staffed by linguists
and they do, in fact-- when
they come up with a name,
they put in all the
semantic associations
with a possible name
but they also do
all the sound symbolic things.
So these are known things.
And then I've asked restaurants
about their menu design
and, I think, some of this
they don't do systematically.
They don't tend
to hire linguists.
I've talked to chefs
of local restaurants
and they're just
busy and they just
make a menu that looks
right to them, artistically
and, of course, they're in
a particular social strata.
They're influenced
by the context.
So I think they have
excellent instincts about how
to appeal to the customers they
want to appeal to and so they
don't do it systematically,
but I think they're appealing
to the same things and that's,
of course, how we study it,
is by noticing that they
have this instinctive model
that we're capturing.
AUDIENCE: So did you just
mentioned an example where,
and I think this is
the most common case,
where people try to appeal
to their customer base?
Now, have you thought of,
do you know of applications
where a company can use
linguistics to actually shape
the consumer preference?
And I could give you an example
of what I'm thinking about.
There are some
ethnic foods that are
trendy among the
majority of a population.
Right?
Why everyone in college
eats instant ramen soup
but they would reject
another ethnic item, right?
Or why sushi or other foreign
dishes have become so popular.
How can you use to actually--
DAN JURAFSKY: Create preference.
Yeah.
The short answer
is, I don't know.
Here's a paradox.
If you look at the menus
for foods in general
and you just look at the price
by ethnicity, price by cuisine,
the expensive cuisines
are all European.
The cheap cuisines
are all Asian,
except for Japanese food.
So sushi is an
expensive cuisine,
you can have a very fancy
Michelin-starred Japanese
restaurant.
Very uncommon to have a
Michelin-starred Chinese
restaurant, even though
that's the most common food
in America, or a
Thai restaurant.
So why is that?
Don't know.
It has to do with history and
social class and our perception
and presumably we can
change these things,
but I'm taken by the fact that
Mexican food and Chinese food
are perceived socially
differently than French food
and Japanese food.
That seems to me
very hard to change
and so somebody will
figure how to change it
and then these
things will change.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
what implications
you think this has for
the dynamics of inequality
in society because
it seems like there's
this inexorable thing--
I think it's totally game
theoretic-- that the
mid-priced guys try to emulate
the high-priced guys
to be aspirational,
then the high-priced guys
have to be different to keep
being different.
But there are societies
with more or less inequality
and even our society's been
more and less inequal over time.
Do you think you see
that in the food?
Do they have to lay
down their arms?
What drives that, apart from--
DAN JURAFSKY: That's
a great question.
I don't know the answer but
it'd be a great question
to study which is,
could we correlate
some of these
differences in language
with societal inequality?
I mean, this
particular data set--
that only works for
places where they
have menus online because
that's what I used,
but that's a lot of places.
Right.
It's mostly the first
World but there's still
inequality differences
in the First World
and you could see
if they correlate
with these kind of things.
That would be cool.
AUDIENCE: In the
last election cycle,
there was that
famous thing about,
take his latte-drinking
whatever, whatever--
DAN JURAFSKY: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It was interesting
how much of that
was, like you said,
to serve identity
and self-signaling around.
I'm not a Starbucks
guy or whatever.
DAN JURAFSKY: We pretend that
there is no social class here
but there is clearly
social class here.
AUDIENCE: I wonder,
could linguists
be part of the solution?
Could you find tricks
to turn it around.
Does it have to be a populist
revolt or could there,
you know--
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah.
I understand.
There are linguists-- so,
people like George Lakoff, who's
a linguist who works with
the Democratic Party-- trying
to think about, for whatever
your message is, how to come up
with the right metaphors
that appeal to the thing
that you're trying-- it's
the same thing as propaganda.
It's the same thing
as advertising.
It's how do we get our
message across in the way--
AUDIENCE: Come across as
aloof and professorial--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah.
How do I get someone else
to think like I think?
That's language.
Right.
That's just telling them
a fact because I want
them to know this thing I know.
Really, it all
boils down to that.
In the bad end, it's propaganda.
In the good end,
it's persuasion.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you have lots of
examples of food influencing
language and linguistics.
Have you seen cases
of the other direction
where you have the language
influencing the food more
directly?
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah,
that's a good question.
Like a case where, because
it was named a certain way,
the food kind of evolved to look
like its name in some cool way.
No but now I'm going
to think about it.
And It would be a great case.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
your model on the Reddit pizza
requests.
Using your probability
model, could you
come up with the perfect request
and would you get a pizza?
DAN JURAFSKY: Yes, so Tim
Althoff, the main author
on that paper, did, in
fact, try getting a pizza
by using all of the features
that were supposed to work
and he got a pizza.
So the short answer is yes.
Of course, some of
these are honest signals
and some are dishonest signals.
So an honest signal is something
that you can't really fake
or that are more
difficult to fake.
So if you really do need the
pizza because your true story
is that you're absolutely
broke and you can't get out
of your house and
all these things,
you're more likely
to get the pizza.
So some of these things
make a lot of sense.
Others are more
linguistic dressing.
AUDIENCE: I'm fascinated
by the way you've
traced the history
of particular foods
and I'm just curious if you
could tell us a little bit more
about your research methods.
Where do you find
from those sources?
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah,
so the ketchup--
it's absurdly simple now.
It was much harder when I
started 20 or 30 years ago.
So, the ketchup story is in
the Oxford English Dictionary
and it was written
by James Murray,
the great editor of the
Oxford English dictionary.
In 1890, he figured out that
ketchup came from Chinese
because a missionary
in China mailed him
an entry from his dictionary
because he had figured it out
because he was talking to people
who were still using the word
to mean the fish sauce.
It's, by now, died
out, but in the 1880s
it was still being used as a
word for a kind of fish sauce
and somebody wrote it down.
All etymology, you always
start with the Oxford English
Dictionary.
But then it turns out that-- the
other thing the Oxford English
Dictionary gives you is it
gives you the first citations
of the word.
So when I was teaching
at Boulder 20 years ago
and I wanted to look at that
East India Company guide
to Asia in 1690, I had
to request microfilm
from some other university, I
had to wait till it arrived,
then I had to go downstairs
into the library basement
and read the microfilm.
And now it's on Google
and you can search it.
So if you look at the book and
you could just look for all
uses of the word
ketchup in there.
So the methods are much simpler.
There's not that many
books written before 1800
and they're all there so
you can search them all.
So the research is
much more fun now
because you can do
it in your bathrobe.
It's very exciting.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
different languages might have
different distributions of soft
versus sharp sounds and, if so,
what that would say about the
origins of those languages?
DAN JURAFSKY: Oh,
great question.
So yes, there are certainly
different distributions
of all sorts of things
across linguistically.
I would say sound symbolism
is a cool phenomenon
but is probably not a strong
factor in language change.
So these two things, the
front versus back vowels
and the soft versus the
sharp things, they do
seem to affect
meaning and maybe they
were important in how
meaning might have evolved
for language, but there's
so many other factors that
have much more magnitude
in how languages change
and how languages evolve.
Simplicity of
articulation in the mouth
is a much stronger
drive for how words
change their pronunciation,
say, than this kind
of sound symbolic thing.
That being said, there
are some differences
but they seem to be
cultural differences.
So, for example, this
finding that carbonated water
is associated with sharp
sounds and flat water
with round sounds was
not true in a study
done in a tribe in Tanzania.
So that may be true
only in Western society
where we perceive carbonated
water as sharp, somehow,
or more acidic than flat
water but that's not
a universal thing, necessarily.
AUDIENCE: A follow-on to
the Reddit pizza question,
did you find that there was
any upper limit to how long you
could go or how tragic your
circumstances or whatever you
could go before people
started going like, OK,
this person wrote an entire self
post and then like 20 comments
detailing how terrible
everything is and how
they'll definitely repay you
with a car or something--
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah.
Yes.
Basically the question is, is it
linear, or is there a ceiling,
or is it is there an
inverse u-shaped curve
where if it gets too
long it dies out.
I don't know.
We didn't look for that.
We just looked for
the main effect
and there's clearly a
main effective of length
and evidentially but
it could very well
be that if you carry it too
far, you don't get rewarded.
AUDIENCE: I think someone asked
about food affecting language.
I can't help but think of
the scrambled eggs at Google.
I've been comparing scrambled
eggs at different places.
Sometimes they seem
really, really scrambled
and sometimes they seem
like they were turned over.
The word in Spanish
for scrambled eggs
is, huevos revueltos.
DAN JURAFSKY: [INAUDIBLE]
turned over, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
if the person who's
making the eggs, if they're
thinking in Spanish revueltos,
they turn the egg over and they
don't really scramble it up,
like really scrambled.
So this is like Whorf hypothesis
linguistic relativism--
DAN JURAFSKY: No, that's
a great question and--
AUDIENCE: My question?
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah.
Yeah.
If that's true, that's
a great example.
There's another hypothesis,
so in some languages
the word for soup is masculine.
In some languages the
word of soup is feminine.
And so you could look at
people speaking languages
with different genders for
different kinds of foods.
Are those foods,
in fact, associated
with masculine or
feminine qualities?
So there's a cute study
showing that bridges--
I'm going to get this
wrong-- but German
and Spanish have the opposite
genders for bridges and people
asked to associate
bridges with things
in German-- German
and Spanish speakers,
which way does the gender work?
AUDIENCE: Female in German.
DAN JURAFSKY: Female in German?
How about in Spanish?
AUDIENCE: Male.
DAN JURAFSKY: Male.
There we go.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Portugese
it's feminine.
DAN JURAFSKY: Yeah.
People gave word
associations for bridges
very differently in
German and Spanish
and they were gender-biased.
AUDIENCE: Just very quickly,
I think you'd appreciate this,
next time you're
in a supermarket,
pick up a can of
macadamia nuts and think
of the poor graduate
school student who
had to write the description
for something that
has basically no taste, or is
it very hard to describe taste?
You can see that the person
was really struggling.
DAN JURAFSKY: Tastes are
very hard to describe
and there are actually
huge differences
but languages, in general,
have very few words for smells,
for example.
Smelling is just a very
hard thing, linguistically,
to describe.
Most of the words
for smells are words
of the thing that it smells
like, like metallic, let's say.
Cantonese, my
favorite language, is
famous for having like
seven words for bad smells
that are very distinct.
There's the moldiness of
bread, and the moldiness
of wet things, and the
stinkiness of-- there's
the urine smell.
So some of them just do
have more words for smells
but, in general, this seems
like it's very difficult
to turn taste and
smells into words
except by just
naming the object.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Please
join me in thanking
Dan for coming to Google today.
DAN JURAFSKY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]